uh here I am at the front of house I
have no idea where the Steve's door is
if only someone had told me from facing
MPS over the party Gate scandal to
slipping past theatergoers at the stage
door I didn't mean to come across at all
as misleading but Tom Cruise has said
that I can have dressing room one from
now on so I'd like my usual Rider please
or the champagne and uh girls Boris
Johnson's rubber doppelganger set to
feature alongside some rather familiar
faces as the satirical puppet show
spitting image comes to London's West
End
it's the staying of seeing these famous
people in in ingrotesque so this sort of
an amplified version of them kind of
saying the things you really want them
want to hear them saying the opposite of
unanimous is tired in its prime back in
the 80s 15 million viewers used to tune
in to watch spitting image
just have had a lucky Escape not
featuring in the show back then as
during its 18 Seasons it was brutal in
some of its takedowns of course Society
has changed a lot since then well has it
well there's no such thing as Society
but there is such a thing as a party my
idea
so in the age of online outrage where we
are perhaps more mindful about not
focusing on physical flaws is the show
still able to be as Savage
people want us to go way way further so
there are parts of the show that we've
made even more outrageous because the
public it's like the Coliseum people are
there and they just want to see they
want to see blood
while the former prime minister might
have a starring role in this stage show
ironically for Boris Johnson between the
partygate Scandal and the covert inquiry
this may well be the least controversial
of all the appearances he has to make
Katie Spencer Sky News